商品サービスには自信があって
実際に使ってくれた人の満足度は高いのに
なぜか売上が伸びない
という悩みをお持ちの方は多いと思います
その原因は商品力のせいだと思っていませんか
実は多くの会社が見落としている
根本的な問題があります
それは伝え方です
いくら商品が良くても
それが正しく伝わらなければ売れません
なぜならお客様は伝わったことしか評価できないからです
こんにちは
マーケティングコピーライターの木沼純一です
私は日本一のマーケッターと呼ばれる
神田正則と協調で
コピーライティング技術大全や
売れるコピーライティング単語帳など
累計18万部以上の書籍を出し
センスや感覚に頼らない
再現性あるコピーライティング技術を広めています
今回はなぜ商品やサービスの魅力が
伝わらないのか
そしてどうすれば伝わるようになるのかを
コピーライティングの技術から解き明かします
その鍵になるのが
PMM
プロダクトマーケットマッチングという考え方です
これは提供する価値と市場のニーズを
ぴったり合わせることです
ではどうやってマッチさせればいいのか
私はこのPMMを
次の3つでシンプルに定義しました
誰が何をしてどうなった
誰が
どんな悩みや理想を持った人が対象か
全ての人に届けたいでは
誰にも刺さらないのが現実です
何をして
自社の商品サービスは
他とどこが違うのか
差別化のポイントを曖昧にすると
価格競争に巻き込まれます
どうなった
その商品を使って
お客様はどう変わるのか
その先にどんな未来が待っているのか
ここが最も大切です
例えばこんな風に表現します
愛犬のストレスから
ドッグサロンに連れて行けないと悩む
40から50代の女性が
出張ドッグサロンチェーン
国内No.1のワンちゃん出張シャンプーを利用して
愛犬がストレスなくシャンプーできるようになった
その結果
愛犬も飼い主も
心理的にも身体的にも健康になった
このように誰が何をしてどうなったでコンセプトを考えることで
お客様が自分ごととして受け取れるストーリーになります
この3つを明確にすれば
商品やサービスの価値が
言葉として立ち上がってきます
私はこの技術を
講座や企業研修を通じて
多くのビジネスパーソンに届けてきました
そして実際に
社内の営業成績が向上した
プレゼンが刺さるようになった
などの成果が出ています
価値を伝えるとは
相手の変化を描くことです
誰が何をしてどうなった
この3つを言葉にするだけで
伝わり方は変わります
伝える技術は経営の力になる
私はそう信じています